it's always good to see the same problem
done more than one way and it's
especially two of these ratio problems
because they in general can be done in
many many different ways and different
types of ways jell with different people
so I just did a video on this where I
said that the ratio of apples to oranges
it starts off at five to eight and we
take away 15 we take away 15 apples and
the ratio becomes one to four and then
the question that we have to answer is
how much total fruit do we have after
taking away the 15 apples and we figured
it out we figured out that it's 50
pieces of fruit but let's see if we can
do it a different way the last time I
kind of talked through it and you know
used a lot of words let's see if we can
do it a little bit more algebraically so
let let a let a is equal to the number
of apples number of apples we are
starting with number of apples starting
with and let I guess o equal the number
of oranges that doesn't change
throughout the whole problem number of
oranges number of oranges so we're
starting off with a apples and a and o
oranges so the ratio of a to O the ratio
of a to O is equal to what the ratio of
a to let me actually well instead of
trying to fit this whole problem into
this part of the screen let me just copy
and paste this part and do it at the
bottom part of the screen let me copy it
and then let me scroll down here where I
have some extra real estate because I
think I'm going to need more than that
little pocket of area right there so I
copied and pasted it just like that okay
so there we have a is the number of
apples to start with and O is the number
of oranges so we could write we do it in
the color that I haven't used before
actually haven't used white so we can
say that the ratio of apples to oranges
is equal to five to eight that's what
they tell us to read that the number of
apples we start with divided by the
number of oranges or the ratio of them
have to be a little bit more particulars
five to eight then we remove 15 apples
so if we remove fifteen apples how many
apples do we have we have a minus
fifteen apples and they tell us that the
ratio of then the number the ratio
of apples to oranges becomes one to four
so a minus 15 which is the number of
apples we start with minus 15 the ratio
of that to oranges is equal to 1 over 4
and let's see if we can solve these two
equations I have two equations here and
I have two unknowns let's see what we
can do here and I probably shouldn't
have labeled there's a reason why oh
isn't used in algebra a lot because it
looks just like a zero but I'll try to
be careful
so this first let me write down my two
equations over here never hurts to
rewrite it
the original apples to oranges ratio
apples to oranges is five to eight then
when we remove 15 apples the ratio of
our new number of apples to oranges is
equal to one over four this is just an
algebraic way of stating our problem of
stating our problem so let's see if we
can solve this if we cross multiply both
sides of this equation we get eight a is
equal to five oh that's not a zero is
equal to five Oh or if we subtract 500
from both sides we get eight a minus 500
is equal to zero so this is just a
linear equation with two unknowns now
what do we get on this right hand side
we cross multiply we get 4a minus 60 I'm
just multiplying four times a minus
fifteen that is equal to one times Oh
or we could just write well I'll write
one oh that's not a ten that's 100 or
one orange and if we rearrange this if
we subtract the 100 from both sides we
get 4a minus 100 minus 60 is equal to
zero or if we add 16 to both sides we
get 4a minus 100 is equal to 60 and here
you might recognize that these are just
two linear equations right here that's
one of them and that's the second up of
them and I have two unknowns I have a
and oh I probably should have called
them x and y to prevent this Oh from
looking so confusing because that's a
zero and that's a no but I think you get
what I'm saying so how do we solve this
well what we can do is we can multiply
one of these times the convenient factor
and then add them or subtract them to
get rid of one of the two variables so
let's do that let's multiply this
equation times minus two so it becomes
minus 8a plus 200 is equal to minus 120
I just multiplied this equation right
here times -2 I do that and then if I
add it to this equation right here this
equation is 8a minus 5 0 is equal to 0
what do I get
let's just add these two equations this
becomes 0 a minus 5 plus 2 is minus 300
is equal to minus 120 or oh is equal to
you divide both sides you can ignore
this divide both sides by minus 3 you
get o is equal to 40
o is equal to 40 so let's see so the
orange is is equal to 40 and that's
before and after the o never changes o
is equal to 40 so what are our apples
equal to we could go to either of these
equations we could go to any of these
that we have maybe we could go to this
one so we have 8 times our number of
apples is equal to 5 times the number of
oranges five times the number of oranges
or five times 48 times the number of
apples is equal to 200 or the apples is
equal to 200 over eight which is equal
to 100 over four which is equal to 25 so
remember what a and Oro is the number of
oranges we have throughout the problem a
is the number of apples we start with
that's what we start with we start with
so you can say that we start with 25
apples 40 oranges or we start with start
with 65 pieces of fruit 65 fruit then if
you were to move 15 fruit you will end
up with 50 fruit which is the exact same
answer we got the other way of doing
this problem and it's nice to see it
done two ways
you want to know the number of apples we
end up with we started with 25 apples if
you were take 15 away from them you're
going to get 10 apples so you start with
25 apples 40 oranges 65 fruit you end
with 10 apples 40 oranges or 50 fruit
either way hopefully it was reasonably
useful to find see this done another way